i i don't know if
history
wants to have kamala as the first women
president i'd much rather have hillary
as the first and i know that sounds very
weird
to say that but
it's very weird like you have a choice
between kamala and hillary to be the
first ever
unbelievable
she dropped out of this it's not listen
the answer is neither yeah the answer
isn't like i'm i'm not sitting here
campaigning saying i'm gonna
volunteer to go help hillary but
there's no way
at least at least hillary
you know
hillary was you know
a person that could get up and
articulate a message you know she's bs
and you know she's just saying whatever
it's going to take at that time
but have you heard kamala given some
answers and she's always laughing and
she's got that weird vibe of the way she
speaks that
i don't actually don't even think it's
close i think hillary is way more
qualified than a kamala okay whether you
like hillary or not robotic you know
paid whatever she's killing people
whatever you want to say about hillary
fifty percent of america voted for her
to be president she went to yeah and she
and she lost
by a slim margin to donald trump kamala
didn't even get one percentage of the
democratic primary vote it's not even
and called the first race
but here let me let me toss on my tin
hat for a second because that very
statement i think justifies an exit of
biden at some point derm is during his
term because the progressives will have
the opportunity in kamala with her
influence will have the opportunity to
go the first ever female
african-american president did not earn
given right participation trophies are
real in america
that's what it seems like for me will
happen even if it's six months out or
something i don't know but yeah but it's
not earned
let me let me let me give you a dark
dark perspective that i have in this
topic
uh how much influence you think hillary
has today in america a lot okay
i think a lot
oh bro bro let me tell you my assessment
but again i'm fully i'm a business guy
i'm an entrepreneur i'm not a guy that's
involved in this world but i will tell
you this
i think
she has a lot of influence and i think
the reason
why biden may not step down
if there is even is any influence left
is because of hillary that hillary
will not
she cannot accept
kamala being the first president
i don't think i think if hillary has any
influence
she's probably the one that wakes up
every morning telling biden's assistant
to give him vitamin c to give the
vitamin b12 yeah to give him trt to give
him whatever it is that he's on to just
make it for two and a half more years
because hillary over her dead body to
have kamala be a president before her
anybody but kamala she would be okay for
michelle to be the first president
she would not be okay with them all
being in the first breath so i think i
think in a way hillary's keeping biting
in office for another tournament by the
way i don't think your assessment is
fully wrong at all
if you're talking about someone like
hillary and you're seeing that if kamala
just gets kind of caked walked into the
presidency hillary's like this does not
sit well with me at all but it's how
much money i spend on my celebration
party you know i didn't go down i really
think that part of biden's main if he
can have these thoughts is not letting
hunter blow him up
just keeping that thing so that thing
doesn't explode
truly because that could just open up
pandora's boxes so much and you know
he's never that's why governors make
good presidents because they've run
something a state they've made big
decisions when you're a senator for 40
years what have you done you run for
office every once in a while you take
handouts you know you vote but you're
not a leader you know you don't do that
kind of thing so i think
this whole hunter you know it's so funny
because if i have an extra muffin at
starbucks shonda knows and i get in
trouble i can't get away with anything
100 biden get away with all you get in
trouble for having a muffin
have you ever not been black have you
not met her yeah
well yeah i mean uh dude i love trump jr
great great dude and i'm like i can't
imagine under um
trump's presidency if he did one like
one ounce of like the the ton that by or
hunter has done like
do we they just completely ignore it now
like as if it's totally fine to be
smoking crack and having sex with
prostitutes and all these other things i
mean do you buddy it looks like you're
having a lot of fun but you know not as
the
president i don't know if it's ignored
it's like an embarrassment man yeah i i
agree with you i don't there's nothing
there's nothing attractive about the
president's son smoking crack with
hookers no doubt the question is did he
sell his country out or not and that's
remains to be seen so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]